♪♪
- I'm Zach.
- I'm Ned.
- I'm Eugene.
- And I'm Keith, and this is
ALL: "Squad Wars!"
♪♪
Oh, hi there.
Yeah, baby,
get it, baby!
♪♪
Please welcome Jake Pavelka.
Cat Zingano.
Three of the most iconic
drag queens
to ever grace the runway.
Rebecca Black.
Kendall Schmidt.
And Dante Basco,
a.k.a. Rufio!
You will become a race car
pit crew.
Bollywood dancers.
Professional wrestlers.
Oh, my God!
He was murdered!
And each week,
two of us will be joining in
on the fun.
Ahhh!
Oww!
Let's get beautiful.
- Yeah!
- [applause]
- [shrieks]
- [laughter]
Oh, this could be
a disaster.
And each episode
will feature
a different guest judge.
Lance Bass!
Lance Bass, baby!
Lance Bass.
♪♪
The winner of the episode
will receive
the ultimate trophy
in reality competition:
the Tryphy.
You can suck it,
Nobel Peace Prize.
[tires screeching]
Ahh!
Keep your hand up,
don't go down.
- Mmmm.
- Thank you, okay.
♪♪
I want to thank you guys
for my inviting me
into your squad.
Oh, well, thank you--
Oh!
What?!
♪♪